well signs of a safer downtown in the
Las Vegas recent stats for Metro Police
show crime is down in the area compared
to this time last year good evening to
you I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Denise
Valdez so this comes after a spike in
violence on and around Fremont Street at
the beginning of the year Sasha Loftus
spoke with people in that area tonight
and she joins us downtown with the
latest
[Music]
Nissan Brian many we spoke with down
here say they're happy to see these
numbers go in a good direction
especially after that uptick in crime we
saw in the area earlier this year you
know you have your days where it can be
bad and days where it's good talking
safety in downtown Las Vegas throughout
this last year it's been an uptick and a
Slowdown it's been a Hot Topic these
past few months after two tourists died
in a hit-and-run crash late last
December
then two people were shot near Fremont
Street experience's Third Street stage
the very next night since then action
has been taken including an increased
presence of Metro Police in Las Vegas
city Marshals
metal detectors were also placed at the
entrances to the experience for a while
in February the Las Vegas city council
also approved adding a new police
substation to the area the concept of
giving your car to them knowing who you
are that was enough for it to kind of
calm down those we spoke with say they
have seen a difference in fact Metro
numbers show crime in the downtown area
is down with homicides robberies and
property crimes dipping 15 to 25 percent
compared to this time last year as of
recently I feel like it's become a lot
safer and a lot smoother it's something
people here say they're happy to see
as they soak up everything this part of
Las Vegas has to offer always a lot of
people around so it's fun now as for
that new substation City officials say
it is said to go right here at this
intersection at 4th and Fremont
reporting downtown tonight social Loftus
8 News Now